بنشوف ظهروا رواد الفضاء بداوا يخرجوا من
مركبه الدراجون شاهدنا احد الرواد
الامريكيين
الرائده خرجت من
دخلت المحطه الفضاء الدوليه الان يبدو هذا
هو الرائد الامريكي ايضا يخرج
وخلينا نشوف
طيب وهذا علي علي القرني يدخل الان الى
محطه الفضاء
الدوليه طبعا هذه اللحظات التاريخيه
بيسلموا على بعض وبيحتفوا
بوصولهم نحن كمان في انتظار دخول ريانه
ايضا
الان خلينا نقول انه طبعا علي القرني هو
يعني دارس لعلوم الطيران في كليه الملك
فيصل الجويه وبيعمل مقاتل برتبه نقيب طيار
على طائرات اف 15
هو كمان يعني احد الشخصيات ايضا البارزه
وجالس بيسلم عليهم وهو مقلوب طبعا مع
انعدام الجاذبيه يلا نزلوه دخلت ريانه
برناوي الان الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه اذا
مشاهدينا بنشاهد الان ريانه
البرناوي اول يعني امراه عربيه سعوديه
مسلمه بتصل الى الفضاء ومحطه الفضاء
الدوليه طبعا احنا الان بنشاهد امامنا هذه
لحظات تاريخيه لحظات طبعا يعني
كلنا يعني نشعر في خلالها طبعا بالسعاده
وبالفخر وسعيدين جدا بوصولهم بالسلامه
وبهذا الانجاز التاريخي لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات